in the Iranian capital today the
country's supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei addressed theology students
death to opposes of the leader they
chant death to America death to the UK
there will be no engagement with America
he tells them no talks no negotiation
he made no direct reference to America's
assertion that his country was
responsible for the weekend strike on
the two Saudi oil plants across the Gulf
to the West in Saudi Arabia the Saudi
Energy Minister made his first public
statement about the attack on his oil
refineries Prince Abdul Aziz bin Salman
has been in the job just two weeks but
unlike Ally America he would not be
drawn on who was responsible the last
two days the damage has been contained
and more than half of the production
capabilities that were damaged as a
result of the attack have been recovered
for now this is as much as we've seen of
the damage to the plants which took out
half of the country's oil production
satellite images released by America
which they now claim will form part of a
collection of evidence which will prove
that this was a multiple missile strike
from inside Iran not from Yemen debris
has now been collected from the scenes
it's likely US Secretary of State Pompeo
will use this as part of America's case
against Iran when he visits Riyadh in
the morning Saudi King Salman told his
cabinet that they were cowardly attacks
on world oil supplies he's building a
case for international support but for
now the Saudis still appear reluctant to
implicate Iran directly they are surely
anxious about being on the front line of
any potential military escalation
instead they're calling for a UN
investigation
in America President Trump continued
with a somewhat muddled message whether
by design or not he said he might meet
the Iranian president but he'd prefer
not to he's ready to attack but might
not his vice president was more explicit
I promise you we're ready as the
president said we don't want war with
anybody but the United States is
prepared we're locked and loaded and
we're ready to defend our interests in
our allies in the region given the
global impact of this attack and the
evidence America claims to have Donald
Trump feels compelled to build a case
against Iran but not yet at least a case
for war